So we've completed discussing the lock-based synchronization
algorithms for a multiprocessor. So how about
we close this section of the lesson with a quiz? What I want you
to do is, we've talked about several different algorithms, spin on test and set,
spin on read, spin with delay. TIcket
lock, Anderson's queue lock, array based, MCS link
based queue lock. So these are the
different algorithms that we've looked at. And along
the way, I mentioned some of the attributes that we look for latency for getting
the lock, contention when locks are released,
fairness whether the spin is on a. Private
variable or a shared variable. How many
read modify write operations are required for acquiring
a lock? And what are the space overhead associated
with the lock? And when the lock is released, are
we signaling one guy or are we signaling everybody?
So all of these are different attributes that you can
associate with these different. Block algorithms, and what I
would like you to do is take your time and
read the algorithms by filling this table, and of
course, you should go back and look at these algorithms
to get a clearer understanding if you find yourself not
ready yet to fill out this table, so take your time.